um look at what kind of shirt we got on
we should probably even just not even
say anything about it but somebody sent
me this I can't remember who I guess
sent a lot of [ __ ] okay you blow get
sent a lot of [ __ ] and I forget all it
was the caffeine and kilos guys that's
who it was but it's the Albuquerque news
13 local local news okay what is it KR q
ue q e cake Kirk
cake Kirk Kirk's Kirk's Wow okay Kirk
why is that everything is K on a radio
which is just like the way they did it
in [ __ ] when they first started doing
radio in 1710 and then they put that at
a K on it hi welcome to KK kill Kara qk
k r KR k qk k welcome welcome to the KKK
we're all we do all whites all the time
KKK we play Hank Williams all day long
KKK welcome to a k'kaw k'kaw do when
when when when radio announces they'd
really do we just was aw you know but
they really [ __ ] go hit home that
doubled you
well it's www.youtube.com
www.calculated.com/support
what is his [ __ ] name and what's his
name ed Sheeran or if you out of here
have you wanna hear Chris Bradley piece
of [ __ ] other weather here we go alive
well having a concert crystal Bradley is
backstage beaut Underwood
we have a good route log-log fly ball
deep to center you know about when they
go that when they do that
I love how I used to try to do this bit
on stage about how bad this is here's an
example of a comedian that trying to do
a bit on stage never [ __ ] worked and
maybe one day I'll do it but I don't
think so because I don't like to do
impressions but I always thought it was
funny how how how what do you call it
the announcers would announce everything
that was going on in either the baseball
players life or anything else in the
world more important than the actual
baseball game like to be like they'd be
like todd zeile steps up to bat todd
zeile hails originally from Fort
Lauderdale Florida he made his move over
to the Cardinals later on in life when
he moved to st. Louis with his family
that's his kids not his mom and dad as
mom and dad stayed in the southern tip
of Florida for most of his childhood
life and even well into the adult I
believe they're still there swinging a
Miss strike one
like that's how they would do it and I
would never be able to get it to work on
stage cuz it's just like a
conversational joke but that's how they
[ __ ] do it
I would always [ __ ] I would always I
try to do that bit maybe MA maybe six
seven eight nine ten times they'd be
like hands leme Yulin steps up to bat
hailing from wherever the [ __ ] he hails
from who knows his name is Hensley
nobody's name has ever been Hensley in
the world
his parents apparently had him come out
and when he came out of his mom's [ __ ]
his dad said well that looks like it
Hensley might as well be from Mars
because we've never heard that name
before in our lives and it also doesn't
pair well with mule ins so that's very
odd that his name would be Hensley mule
ins keeps his eye on the ball ball one
John all Roode steps up to the plate is
batting averages 400 which is
unbelievable for some reason he was an
amazing hitter later on in the in his
career wasn't that good in the beginning
of his career and the only guy who wears
a
Helmuth while playing first base
apparently he's that much of a [ __ ]
that he gets so scared to get hit in the
head by a baseball even though he's
ready for it because he's playing first
base and should always know when the
ball is coming to him fly ball deep to
center and he's out anyway k
www.kbtoyota.com
[Music]
George Brett up to bat digs into the
place digs into the plate sorry said
place because George Brett [ __ ] all over
the place last time I George Brett last
night had doubled a bird [ __ ] and long
fly ball deep to right field that he's
out and he should have passed oh good oh
good he's taking shower go it is a busy
[ __ ] shower